let's stay with the phones let's go next
to our caller from the eight five six
area code caller from eight five six
tell us who you are and what's on your
mind today hi there my name is Sun I
I'm from Cherry Hill New Jersey and I
wanted to ask Dave the Conservatives
love to attack progressive people haters
know money on military but at what point
if you are against it they'd like to
attack you that you're not patriotic so
how do progressive seem like hey we're
spending way too much of money but we
are people and we're doing this out of
patriotism that you know you know you
don't think it's a good idea to
constantly increase the budget to go to
the military industrial complex yeah
well so I think it's it's very important
to make it clear that just throwing
money at the military is not an act of
patriotism and in the same way that
money can be used in productive or
unproductive ways in every other
instance on this planet just adding more
money to the military does not guarantee
that we're actually going to have better
national security outcomes it doesn't
really guarantee anything so we need to
be thinking a little bit more critically
about how the money is being used but I
think there's another aspect to this
right which is that there's this
irrational assignment of so-called
patriotism to having the biggest
possible military but we need to sort of
change the discourse and point out that
actually what's really patriotic is
valuing the service the valuing the
service of those in the military so much
that the sort of criticism or critical
analysis of when we use the military is
one of the most patriotic things that we
can do anybody can sign off on a piece
of paper to dump billions of dollars on
the military but there's nothing
objectively patriotic about that in fact
it's sort of a blind action that doesn't
really it's a reflexive action that
requires no thinking more patriotic
would be hey we are lucky enough to have
an all-volunteer army we don't need the
draft because so many people are willing
to say hey I don't have to
I'm gonna choose to serve in the
military and the most patriotic thing we
can do is to really critically think
about when we put troops in harm's way
whether it's actually a good use of that
military service that has been
volunteered and not demanded and of
course implicit in that is thinking
about all the other areas in which money
could be used right what's more
patriotic funding an even bigger
military or making sure that everybody
can have a basic level of health care
for example such that people can
actually work in the field that's their
passion not stick around in some lame
job because they don't want to lose
their health insurance so we need to
reframe the debate on patriotism and
it's sadly become a debate that the
right has had sort of a monopoly on but
the entire thing's got to be rebuilt
from the ground up okay all right Dave
yeah I love your show I think I'm gonna
sign up to be one of your members all
right very good thank you so much really
appreciate the call thank you so much to
all of our callers we will take a break
audience questions coming up stay with
us on the Friday show